hey out there old movie fans it's time
again for a movie retrospective doing
one from 1988 today directed by the
legendary Wes Craven yeah this is the
Serpent and the rainbow I saw this when
it came out Robin it first came out and
I didn't remember thinking it was bad
but I really remember thinking it was
all that good either it just I saw it
we're ended I think on VHS and I watched
it and I was like yeah alright yeah
that's kind of chuckled it off I forgot
all about it I saw it again remember
with you just say the night it was good
real good so you told you it was just I
guess you know I saw it when I saw it I
was young and I was just more into well
this not terminator yeah well every
movie but terminator is not terminator
so did you like every movie wild man
terminator that's not sorry in this [ __ ]
movies that are see that before as
before Bruce Willis Bruce Bruce was
still on TV at that point yeah he didn't
really get famous enough for as an
action hero yeah yeah just been like a
comedian that's what everyone thought
like hey yeah um but yeah it's funny now
because I guess people that were that
weren't born back then and you've always
known and like Bruce Willis as an action
star he did not start it was like it was
kind of like a bit and people were like
what the [ __ ] what is he doing in this
movie that's gonna suck and then they
were like oh okay nevermind yeah well
you know action action movie hero was
like Stallone or oh yeah yeah he's like
a big buff guy and dude he could whip
your ass you know what I mean then they
you know the show Bruce Willis and
people start laughing yeah they did at
the time I remember oh come on
but then the movie was so good they're
like okay yeah
well because he was more of an everyman
character yeah yeah
but he survived some [ __ ] impossible
[ __ ] well yeah but you know it was just
still a cool movie so anyway they just
changed the action movie genre yeah it
really did I mean pretty much
single-handedly single repeatedly I
guess yeah because before that you know
he was just some dude you see on a
sitcom yes you kind of like waiting
kinda like the equivalent I don't know
yeah
wasn't even a James Bond type guy he's
just just a dude it'd be like saying
Jerry Seinfeld Jerry Seinfeld's good for
you Bruce Willis got that on his
tombstone just to do this dude yeah
well first uses what people should have
that on there - yeah yeah well I started
out he's just kind of generic yeah yeah
so anyway yeah okay so the thing about
serpent in the rainbow I don't I might
have seen it in the theater um because I
was going to the movies a lot around
this time but maybe I didn't but I saw
it probably if I didn't see in the
theater than I saw probably a year or
two after it came out like on VHS like
you did now I actually taped it off
cable and I kept it like I watched it a
lot of times because I really really dug
it and then but then I didn't watch it
for for ages and then recently when
shudder put it put it up I was like oh
we need to do that movie because I've
been it's been on my list and [ __ ] like
that because it was one that I
remembered really liking and it was
actually I mean I liked it at the time
but it was much better than I remembered
yeah so this is actually this is the
movie that was Craven directed after the
unfortunate deadly friend oh I loved
that when I was younger
it's terrible but in kind of an
endearing way I guess this movie made a
lot more sense than I remembered it make
yeah I didn't remember it making much
sense those like what the [ __ ] is this
thing doing you know like what is that I
didn't know much about you know voodoo
lore and I guess I really couldn't
follow it yeah this is something you
kind of have to pay attention to what
they're talking about and like what's
going on yeah and you know at that time
this is a very innovative movie so you
we weren't really you you know customs
so story telling me like this I think
it's all just like um it's almost like a
throwback because because it's
technically it's a zombie movie but it's
more a zombie movie in the sense of like
in the 1940s
you don't mean like I watched this room
where all the zombies were you know
based around Haitian voodoo lore you
know it was just in the
t8 obviously with Nana living-dead that
zombies became like flesh-eating ghouls
and everything like that prior to that
the only thing about a zombie was that
they were Hey it was Haitian like you
brought them back and they were slaves
and whatnot and I said this kind of was
like a throwback to that and it from and
I don't really like the title I don't
think that title is catchy enough to
really catch the attention of you know
at least me when I was when I was the
age that I saw this which I've made late
teens yeah yeah I mean it should have
been surfing in the Rainbows County it
just doesn't sound like a like an
exciting horror movie it should have
been something more like black people
scared shove this white dude white dude
get Boyer's yeah yeah something like
that you know well okay so well people
[ __ ] this white dude over all of them
I know that but you know it was it was
cool though kind of like the setting is
kind of like a James Bond setting yeah
yeah I guess not remember that was it
man of the Golden Gun would've had that
davu was it man with the Golden Gun or
was it I think it was maybe it was you
only live twice was it much something
like that it was one of them too yeah it
kind of had that feel to it because
that's the only thing I could really
associate it with yeah you know but then
after a while it's just it's it's own
thing it's pretty good yeah this said
this is um so if you didn't know I mean
that you know that's called the syrup in
the rainbow because that's what the book
is called
and the book was actually nonfiction
written by ethno botanist Wade Davis who
went down to Haiti in 1985 and was
studying some of the different poisons
and was studying this quote-unquote
zombie powder and was like figuring out
what was in it
and how it was used to make zombies not
in the sensitive they were killing a
person and bringing it back from the
dead obviously but how they were making
it appeared that the person was dead and
then bringing them back and how they
were keeping the person enslaved you
know what I mean yeah and like in like
and like a drugged-out stupor right
that's what they're doing
yeah this dude goes down there try to
figure out the secret of it you know and
and hooks up with this guy who's kind of
like a shyster
real trustworthy and he's gonna sell him
the recipe that's evidently how it went
but in the end they become buddies and
uh the story is pretty cool like I mean
you got the head of a secret police
organization who's representing this
dictatorship and he's just this evil
looking [ __ ] but you see him he's so
good yeah he doesn't get scared not only
can he torture you and he had a sick the
secret police on you he's also gonna
steal your soul yeah make you a zombies
and stuff man pretty cool yeah miles of
[ __ ] zombies he's got a whole vial
full of that room with a budget of vials
and and will vases I guess yeah I think
they're called cannot D yeah like souls
in with the souls of the trap didn't
area because he's a book [ __ ]
yeah he's like a black magic yeah it's
got a lieutenant who's when you first
see him he's in the top added tales
let's go mask I said man I gotta get get
my buddy that out like your Baron Samedi
yeah yeah that's pretty cool and you
know they're just trying to he's trying
to get the secret they're trying to kick
him out of the country and bad [ __ ] in
suit ensues he meets this kind of mixed
chick who's she's a doctor what she's a
doctor yeah yeah she's a doctor and uh
you know he colonizes it he I'm not
gonna say you colonized it and was there
more like gentrified well thank you for
making it is pretty cool and man you
trying to save her and she's trying to
help him and Jenny tell yo details that
was the man short story short that is
the short version a DD man short yes
that was a testosterone infused version
that's a story all right so like I said
that well the interesting thing about
this was that um so I guess like after
the Wade Davis book came out and like I
said obviously all the [ __ ] that happens
in the movie because the movie kind of
takes like a supernatural sort of turn
which obviously the
did not because it was you know a work
of serious anthropology where he went
down there and studied the drugs and
stuff so they just kind of used that as
a jumping off point now one thing that I
didn't know until I was like kind of
research in this movie was that Wade
Davis he agreed to sign off the rights
to make a fiction movie of the book but
only if Peter where directed it and Mel
Gibson starred in it hmm and I don't
think it would have worked
I'm just saying that right now at that
time Mel Gibson made it had a hell of a
box-office draw he did but everybody
wanted him to be in their movies
can you ever and that's another one that
Khanna became an action guy by accident
yeah because Mel gives Mel Gibson and
Bruce Willis worth real similar
physically damages on average guys it's
just kind of funny how that how that
went down
but then somehow Harrison Ford got
thrown in with them with the Patriot
Games and yeah he's playing a secret CIA
agent yeah yeah can you imagine that
like Mel Gibson like running around
Haiti like trying to have a zombie
powder and he'd just be like cracking
jokes it just would have been a totally
different movie that's what I'm saying
yeah cuts down Jews and stuff oh yeah
that's what I mean it's like he'd have
been cussing out everybody his stupid
horrible ass what are you doing there
Jesus Christ I don't think that would
have worked at all but yes now so email
yeah no I think he can make a good movie
though he kept those [ __ ] sometimes yeah
I really do like a [ __ ] you that too and
I feel like that doesn't get talked
about a lot uh-huh you know what I mean
yeah you know that's a kick-ass movie I
feel like this movie um like I said even
though it takes a supernatural turn and
it's very much based in reality um it it
actually is one of the few movies that
actually takes voodoo seriously as the
religion that it is you know I mean it
doesn't make it you know what I mean it
doesn't make it like oh it's all bad or
oh it's you know what I mean it's very
very grounded in how people actually I
went to one of these those things when I
was a kid it was masoom but no but
a friend of mine was a taxi driver he
had to go you know we were hanging out
and he's like man I gotta go to church
and I said what church he goes it turned
out he's some about Macumba yeah so I
said now I take me I check it out he's I
don't know if I should take it but I
went you know you pay to get in you know
you got it like give like a little
offered it was just Church really yeah
Church with girls singing blowing smoke
on people singing at people you don't
really know what's going on the people
are there you know for to solve
different problems and nobody knows what
the problems are on the priest knows
yeah only thing weird about it I thought
was when I was walking in they had some
chickens on a big old long spike it's
probably a four foot tall wire they were
dead you know they just killed him and
yeah put them on that spike but that's
just kind of normal that's you know do
the same thing you know in Judaism you
know sacrifice and goats and yeah that's
a burnt offering so people nowadays
think it's weird but it's really not
that one no it's actually quite
traditional and they don't waste it
yeah yeah and I mean like they say well
it's for the spirits now it's for the
[ __ ] priest
yeah they go and they eat all that need
to shake it yeah but yeah so so this
actually does take it seriously as a you
know as a belief system and it's
probably one of the most serious you
know zombie movies quote-unquote I mean
I've just us got angel heart I think
there was maybe one or two other ones
that believers although I guess that was
that was more like a negative thing but
interestingly so I think in some ways
that's what makes this movie like more
creepy or like more unsettling is
because even though there are
fantastical elements a lot of which are
drug-induced you know I mean like these
like Bill Pullman's character who is
having like hallucinations and whatnot
but it but it then it's very grounded in
reality I mean they did actually shoot
most of this in Haiti until the
political situation started to get kind
of out of hand and you know the their
handlers or whatever said look we can't
ensure your safety anymore so you might
want to get out of here and then they
ended up having to film the rest of it
in the dim
in Republic and a lot of the stuff that
you see like a lot of the voodoo rituals
like near the beginning of the movie
where dr. Duchamp is getting up and
she's possessed those were actually all
locals and that was like a real ceremony
find out actors there so most of the
people in this are not we're not actors
you know I mean other than the main one
like all the people like the extras and
stuff like that they were all people
that were actually from there and they
were doing what they did you know
visually it looks really good it is it's
amazing can't tell it's not a set it's
authentic the only thing is is that some
of the leads there's what you're playing
Haitians you can tell it's not really a
Haitian accent that they're using it's
fake yeah fake French accent I do like
that they recall the dude black it was
that blah blah yeah it's like a white
making jokes in the whole movie about
you know I'm calling him in a block down
it is a fun movie to watch it did kind
of take me back to another time ya know
CG nope just good storytelling and good
practical effects and so lately some
there is some really really really nice
creepy like iconic imagery in this yeah
good acting I mean there's you know
there's that thing with like the creepy
like bride and he pulls back the veil
and she's like a corpse face and then it
comes out of her mouth yeah um you know
there's the one where he's kind of
tripping out and he looks out the you
know occur out of the porch or the door
of his beach house and there's like this
boat coming toward him of the corpse on
the front that's all on fire yeah and
it's just it's really really cool like a
lot all the candlelight and all that
there's a lot of horror imagery but it's
usually associated with some kind of
damn hallucination he's having because
you need took drugs but there's also
because they drugged him him turn it
away try to turn him into a zombie plus
he was also having visions and
premonitions because he was coming under
psychic attack remember yeah yeah
because the main bad guy and another
interesting thing about this too and you
know and they actually were filming this
when this was going on was that this was
around the time when that resolve a
civil unrest it was all the protests
against the dick
baby doc Duvalier and so actually
there's the story of you know Bill
Pullman's character whose name is Dennis
Allen but he's based on Wade Davis a
little bit but not he's more like I
guess he's more like an Indiana Jones
kind of character you notice he's like
an anthropologist type character like an
intellectual and um
but his story of attempting to get the
zombie powder he's trying to get it for
a you know a place called bio core
Portuguese very funny you know why yeah
it's like well that's about what they
would name something like that then so I
didn't think it was that like back then
yeah yeah because back then that's like
everybody wanted this generic name but
it's like so they want to find out what
the zombie because they've heard about
this case of this guy named Christophe
Durand who apparently died in 1978 but
then was seen walking around again many
years later so they figured out it was
Amba powder it must be a drug we need to
get our hands on that how they make that
because we can make that into like a
super anise that it can make like
anesthetic a lot safer so that's why he
goes down there to find it so Christophe
Duran is obviously based on a real guy
clairvius narcisse who was who Wade
Davis talked Mona's book who supposedly
died was buried all that other stuff and
then was brought back you know and was
enslaved for many years or whatever so
that's like a real case that they based
this guy on even though like I said this
one kind of goes in a supernatural
direction and the other one doesn't but
so the story of Bill Pullman's character
is kind of like analogous to you know
even like Haiti fighting back against
the Duvalier family and them leaving the
country like them being ousted from the
country or fleeing the country because
at the end when you know Bill Pullman
like fights the bokor and like you know
does the mental thing like the psychic
thing against him and like ends up
killing him and stuff and releases all
the souls of the people that he had been
keeping that was like it's like a symbol
to for all the people of Haiti who were
like released from
you know the Duvalier you know
dictatorship so they so they definitely
like how to parallel going with that
type of thing even though it was I think
even them in the movie they even use
like real TV footage of baby doc
Duvalier like fleeing the country so I
think like when you see that like on
those that's actual footage of that like
actually happening so there is like a
realistic like a little bit of political
thing in it but mostly I mean mostly
it's a horror movie but it's a very
serious grounded horror movie that has
like a lot of like you said like
horrific elements in it I mean there's
[ __ ] like it's not really I guess it's
not really all that gory um there is a
there is a beheading well there's a
couple beheadings one of them but you
don't see them one of them you just see
the aftermath Bill Pullman does have a
nail driven through his scrotum yes
awesome but you don't really said that's
it that's a really that's a really good
scene because the [ __ ] the guy that
plays you know the head of the tonton
Macoutes who's like not only like the
head of the military police but he's
also like a bokor he's like a black
magician and he can like get inside your
dreams and like [ __ ] with your head and
[ __ ] like that yeah you know he's got
like Bill Pullman character likes naked
and strapped to a chair yeah when I saw
that scene they drove that Nathan dudes
scrotum they don't actually show it the
camera angled you know you can't see it
yeah you could just see the base of it
man that freaked me out when I was when
I first saw this yeah you don't see that
know what my reaction was is that the
times like man when they kill you but
now bad for people we know from the club
we'd have people that would do that to
themselves for fun that's oh yeah it
wouldn't kill you it probably wouldn't
be all that you know it probably
wouldn't be all that fun unless you're
into that but in a way I think that made
it kind of better because like the way
they just showed his face because the
whole guy was like I want to hear you
scream so he's like trying to scream
like before he does it like how's that
and he's like not good enough and then
he's like what on a movie would you
compare this to like I said it's it's
similar
a little bit too angel heart yeah which
yeah we should probably do that I wasn't
this good this you're gonna think I'm
[ __ ] crazy okay
for some reason I always associated this
one with the Last Temptation of Christ
because it under around the same time I
think I saw them around this day yeah I
haven't seen that for really I remember
really like in that movie but I haven't
seen it or some reason like tonally it I
think it was just because I saw them
near each emir each other but for some
reason you know i associate those two
movies yeah like they're related to each
other which that was a good movie too
David Bowie was in it he wants yeah yeah
he played Pontius Pilate that was the
one that had yeah well um Dafoe was in
that right yeah yeah he was like yeah he
played Jesus or whatever had to see that
one for a while yeah let me see that
again I really I don't know if it's
toasted I remember there being a
humongous controversy I went out when
when that came he and Steve me and Steve
took dates to that movie we were waiting
out a lot in just a long line to get in
there yeah we got accosted by churches
with dam signs there yeah like those
ones that used to hang out in downtown
Orlando it is lips yeah they want people
to see Jesus on the big screen which is
absolutely I didn't want to see because
Jesus and Mary Magdalene have sex in
that movie don't they maybe they did
maybe they didn't but I don't think
about a day stands because I don't I
think a lot of Christians for I wouldn't
even care yeah go see Jesus yeah it
might still be but I don't think it I
don't think it would cause the Fuhrer
but that's not that some people say that
that's kind of implied and maybe
possibly the story in order maybe you
could read that into it yeah but they
you're real hardcore ones don't want to
hear that with all the mirror veno the
Jesus bloodline coming through Mary you
know I mean that's all well yeah rumors
like that hundreds of years a lot more
acceptable now I think after that Holy
Blood what was the [ __ ] was that name
with that book Holy Blood Holy Grail
yeah
Christ whatever the [ __ ] it was called I
don't remember yeah and there was like a
whole like a big thing about that yeah
you have devout Christians going yeah I
hope Jesus's blood
mine is still around that means I could
be yeah yeah yeah so yeah people's uh
excuse me people's uh attitudes have
really changed about that kinda [ __ ] a
lot yeah you still have like some fringe
wackos but you know what I mean it's
it's not like it was in the eighties
yeah I mean when Last Temptation of
Christ came out when did that come out
eighty-eight eighty-nine something like
that and uh I rooms people were freaking
out they were freaking out about this
big best religious movie of all times
though it's got to be Noah he loves know
I love that the Darren Aronofsky yeah
that's straight out of for the Permian
it's weird I love it I like Darren
Aronofsky's that's what they're talking
about though yeah that's what they're
talking about but yeah
so um so anyway like I was saying like
this this is very much like like I said
kind of like angel heart or it reminds
me a lot of kind of maybe in the pacing
or kind of the atmosphere of it or
something it kind of reminds me of like
some of the you know 30s and 40s like
the books like I walked with a zombie
and white zombie and stuff like that a
little bit like that just in the sense
that you get the sense of since they
really filmed it in Haiti and they
really used like all the locals as
extras and they tried to make it as
realistic as they could make it within
that framework so you really get a sense
of place and you really get a sense of
this [ __ ] could really happen kind of um
in a way that you don't get when a lot
of other horror movies that's why I said
that it kind of reminded me of a James
Bond movie I mean James Bond went to
Haiti
yes but James Bond movies are very
location centric they are yeah and this
movies like that too is that because
it's actually happening in it in its
proper location as far as you know you
don't know that they moved the film crew
but because it all seems to be Haiti
some of it is Haiti yeah and it just
gives that feel to the movie though you
you could not replicate that tone
without without filming it there with
that with actual people at will real
Haitians yeah and real you know
voodoo people beating on drums and stuff
and you know I mean some of the like you
know there's a like a damn documentary
it
is kind of it has that like look to it
but it's really I mean like I said it's
got such great imagery and it's just
like really beautiful like everything is
just like by candlelight and fire and
then there's just like all these real
like everyone doing the you know the
ceremonies and not they all have red on
and it's just like and they're all
dancing and like sticking like needles
through their cheeks and stuff like that
cause the glasses yeah and there's like
there's this one really gorgeous shot
where they're all like it's like a
funeral procession and they're all
wearing white and they're all carrying
candles and they're all just like going
like through the you know through the
fields or whatever and it's just like
this really nice like long shot but it's
just a really really nice shot and like
I said they this film also not only
plays on I guess like you know various
fears of getting a nail put through your
scrotum and spiders snakes la tarea de
la buried alive this movie the one scene
a particular where you know Bill
Pullman's character Dennis Allen he gets
you know he gets warned again and again
by the taunts I'm accout you know get
out of Haiti but he won't go because he
needs the zombie powder and then
eventually he asked he leaves but then
he comes back because he has to save dr.
Duchamp who he feels is in danger so at
one point you know the book or has
somebody blow the zombie powder on him
which so you know which is another scary
thing because the [ __ ] like soaks
through your skin right and then you die
or it looks like you die you go into a
cat elipse cataleptic state and then you
get buried because everybody thinks
you're dead I mean if you're at the
beginning they show like somebody they
think is dead they're like [ __ ] these
he's got no heartbeat is that they stick
a [ __ ] pin like under his eyeball and
he doesn't react to it so obviously
they're gonna bury you even though
you're still in there and you're still
like aware of what's going on which is
horrifying so that happens to Bill
Pullman's character like he gets the
zombie powder blowing on him and he's
like just going around the [ __ ]
street and you know he's trying to tell
people is very famous I think even the
line is more famous than the movie
itself is or those goodie
don't let them bury me I'm not dead
which is really I saw a review the just
earlier today that said that's probably
one of the best horror movie tag lines
like ever where he's got that [ __ ]
red cross on his forehead it's good foot
and then they throw him in a [ __ ]
coffin and there's just these [ __ ]
shots there's like that you know that
he's the bottom of the grave and then
like put Tran chillin and then like the
creepy dude is up there like looking
down at him and throwing dirt on there
and then like he's you know and it's
like there's just really great like
images of yeah even before that happens
to him like he has a kind of a vision
where he gets like thrown into the
coffin and then it's like starts filling
up with blood and all this other kind of
[ __ ]
so I mean if you're scared of being
buried alive because there's like that
scene where it actually does happen to
him and then like the screen just goes
black for several minutes and then all
you can hear is him just like breathing
and like waking up and like freaking out
and finding out and yet there's a
tarantula in there like crawling on its
face but you know it's like all the
effects and this are good it's like all
the acting is really good you know it's
just a beautiful looking movie and like
I said it's really one of the few
serious real zombie movies that actually
has as a bag has like a serious backdrop
of like you know kind of exploration of
the lore you know in both sides of it
it's like you know how it can be used
for good or how it could be used for
evil because one of the guys that helps
them is like kind of a good voodoo guy
you know a whom gun or whatever they
call it you know so that guy helps him
out so it's not all bad the cast English
like the spot-on it really was and I and
I love that they put Bill Pullman in
this because I think at this point in
his career he had only had two lead
roles maybe he was in Spaceballs and one
other thing but he had mostly been a
comedic actor yeah so I think they they
kind of really he's cast a little bit
against tight but I think he did a
really good job in this the guy who
played the secret police from the book
who a guy man they his face his acting
it just it just sold he was a yeah it's
like I thought if I just play himself he
did a bunch of he was in a bunch of
other movies yeah I'm seeing it when I
first saw this as a kid I was just like
I didn't think that was an actor that's
just like a really evil view guys look
like that yeah he'd look like that
there's just something so he was
intimidating about
and it's just like I think it's like his
voice it's just like the vase his teeth
yeah like the facial expressions that he
makes like the way he carries his body
he's basically kind of like you know a
secret policeman he's running a secret
police squad that's like a death squad
yeah so you're dealing with somebody's
like at the level like a SS that's what
I was thinking it's like the Haitian
equivalent is yes like SS police or
something yeah and he's got the power of
life and death over he can kill you or
throw you into prison or whatever and
he's a damn sorcerer on top of it yeah
he can he can use drugs and potions and
it's not flim-flam Duke could get into
your dreams too you know he does have he
does have paranormal abilities yeah it's
not fake yeah so you know this because
they're hard to beat that there's that
one yes I happen in a third world
country too
this is like some [ __ ] and Bill is like
he doesn't really know that many people
there they say maybe if you take this
story and put it in again in a galaxy
far far away you're talking about Darth
Vader yeah you know the Haitian Darth
Vader yeah and yeah or you know falsi
doom yeah from Konya he comes across
yeah that's the thing it's like he kid
he has everything and so it seems like
he seems like an um an unbeatable foe in
a lot of ways because he has magic
powers I mean there's that one [ __ ]
great scene where like I said they're
trying to get Bill Pullman believe Haiti
and he won't leave for various reasons
and you know so he's starting to
threaten him
and he just has this great thing where
he he says Oh dr. Allen you know what I
mean he's like did you dream about this
that the other no you dreamed about this
and that he says I know because I was
there and I said you know what I mean
because he could like and he's like it I
could be there and every time like so he
could like [ __ ] with your mind like
forever and there's even a CNN at 2:00
like after he leaves um after he gets
the zombie powder and like leaves Haiti
the first time cuz like you know he has
to go back at the end but after he
leaves the first time and he goes back
to Boston and he's at a dinner party
with his friends they're like
celebrating oh yeah he got the zombie
powder or whatever so he's like with his
colleagues and the woman at the like the
wife of his colleague or whatever that's
the dinner party she gets possessed by
that guy who's back in Haiti yeah like
she starts freaking out and like chewing
on glass and that's kind of weird
dynamic you know being an American you
see like the this happened in a
third-world setting these guys got
fucked-up clothes they don't hardly have
any money their government's falling
apart there's no infrastructure how
could this guy really have any true
power no he's got supernatural power
yeah you know myth and he could like I
figure like thousands of miles away yeah
that's a damn sophisticated weapon yeah
and that was one of the things that made
you know dr. Ellen have to go back to
Haiti because he's like one not only was
dr. Duchamp in danger and he had kind of
fallen in love with her the course of
the movie but also because he understood
then he's like I can't escape him he can
get me anywhere because he can and
that's why he did that like why that's
why that guy possessed that girl at the
but there the woman at the party because
he wanted to show dr. Allen it's like I
could just [ __ ] with you forever if I
wanted to yeah it doesn't matter how far
away you are bad English Hank oh stop
him goddamn right
but yeah so seriously I feel like I mean
obviously Wes Craven you know he's made
like a [ __ ] ton of good movies mostly
you know his best one sniper and I was
sure he'd scream but he's made like a
lot of other really good ones in there
that I feel are kind of like not all
that talked about or not and this is
kind of one of them um they say you know
having not seen this one in a long long
time forgotten all about it not really
walking away with it being all that
impressed seeing it now I'm like damn I
can't believe that I didn't appreciate
this at the time it's a great movie it
definitely is it's and it's one I can
see how you know if you're younger and
you're not it wasn't even really a
typical horror movie for its time right
it was like I said it was much more
serious and it's almost kind of like an
anthropological adventure yeah
mystery movie with horror elements on
top of it yeah rather than being just
like a straight-up traditional horror
movie but I'm aged well it really has I
think it you know it really plays just
as well like I said
I liked it even better now that I did
like when I saw it back in the old day
think it might play better now yeah it
might because you know I remember it
being very ahead of its time and the way
the storytelling when everything was
written out yeah it was very weird when
we saw it yeah I remember thinking it
had an experimental feel to it it did
like a little bit of an art house right
but you look at it now and it's actually
just kind of like superior to a lot of
the garbage that they make today this
you could easily play this in a movie
theater right now and get people to go
see it yeah just like you know when they
replayed shining people yeah yeah it was
full yeah it was full they replayed
alien the very first alien and it was
great to see that on the big screen yeah
I was really happy to sit in there there
is there are there really like kids in
their late teens going this movie is so
scary sit down sit down watch the movie
once you traumatized by this movie when
your kid no no I'm gonna traumatize me
watching a damn movie man's a movie he
was side the [ __ ] out but you know it
you could play this today and you you
could people would enjoy it now that I'm
thinking about it
serpent in the rainbow this has almost a
Candyman kind of vibe yeah I was gonna
say that it because it has that
anthropological I was thinking that but
I didn't know maybe there's just because
they had two black villains I didn't
know no I felt like I said I was young
about the tone and the writing style of
the day that's what I mean and I feel
like because it had like an
anthropological focus yeah I think is
what I was thinking of you know what I
mean because in Candyman where she was
like you know she researched urban
legends and she was like trying to
figure out so this is almost kind of
like the same thing where he's going to
like find this [ __ ] he first heard
about this when we were in high school
and it was other high school girls that
recommended it to me and Steve they were
just saying that it was and and to us
back then it was like it was like an
experimental new movie almost kind of
like art house and it was high-tech and
in many ways in the way they're telling
the story because you got a look at what
was around at that time yeah
yeah it's pretty simple pretty simple
true stuff ghostbusters that kind of
stuff although this was four years after
ghostbusters
that's what I was saying yeah so
ghostbusters would have been kind of
like the standard for a Hollywood type
movie yeah this was definitely not I
mean even at the time when this came out
in 1988
I think this only cost about seven
million to make which was pretty low
budget even for then um it didn't do
that
it didn't do badly at the box office but
I don't think it did as quite as well as
they expected I think it made about
nineteen and a half million so it made
like twice its money back which is
usually like I think it was most his
success on VHS yeah I feel like it
probably kind of I mean because Wes
Craven was already you know like a big
name by then because he'd already done
Nightmare on Elm Street we rented it and
he'd already did and you know even back
in the 70s he did [ __ ] Last House on
the Left and and all that so you know I
but I do feel like this is kind of maybe
one of his lesser appreciated ones it's
not a lot like his other movies you know
what I mean it's almost kind of like I
don't want to say it's you know it's
like the odd one out but I guess because
it's based on a nonfiction work it
doesn't come across yes same as a lot of
his other movie I remember I remember
people going oh you got season is a true
story
that's a theory that's waivers yeah I
mean true story based on a true story
kind of yeah I mean it is bit like that
zombie powder shows one really that was
one of the selling points though is that
this is a true story
yeah it was kind of like blur and you
know I mean fantasy and yeah and in fact
we're kind of blurring it and those that
when you're that young you know I I mean
I think the card at the beginning of the
movie says inspired by true events yeah
I don't think it says this is a true
story though when you were like 1718
that's enough this is true not quite
like I said there was a lot of true [ __ ]
in this and they just use and they did
use a lot of you know reality to kind of
jump off of it but I mean but yeah so um
shudder just added this probably like a
week ago they added two shits on a Wes
Craven movie so we're probably be doing
another one in a couple weeks you got to
see this one but yeah this is definitely
one of my favorite
only thing I don't like about the movie
is the title I don't really think that
title fits it I always really liked that
time I thought I always thought it was
like very mysterious and I think the
town I think the tone is a little little
too fantasy sounds like something the
sword source for type stuff yeah I can
say that you know like something with
the unicorns and guys with swords and
[ __ ] dragon sword and sit and a dragon
just one know what it sounds like to me
it should have been called something
else yeah I mean like I said white
zombie would have been perfect cuz
that's what it was white white dude
turned into a zombie that's true that
would have a very straightforward yeah
yeah but then everyone would have
thought it was a remake of like the Bela
Lugosi yeah I think it's really got the
idea that maybe that's where Bela ghosts
got the idea no I don't look as a hat
Baffert yeah it's like back in the
[ __ ] 1940 a long time alright so yeah
if you have shudder they just added this
as well as a couple of other West Craven
Wes Craven movies like two or three
other ones one of which we will probably
be doing in a couple of weeks but I'm
not gonna say which one so you should
definitely go check it out especially
like I said if you like real zombie
movies if you liked angel heart if you
like that type of stuff then you will
probably love this if you haven't seen
it so definitely go check it out